let's go next to our caller from the 954
area code 954 has been holding on for a
little while who's this where you
calling from
is this me yes it is what's up david
it's actually sebastian
calling in from miami great what's going
on
well i want to first start by saying
that to this day i love your show i
actually was the
right winger who called in a few months
ago
asking for career advice for anyone
listening that video is still up if you
want to go check it out
okay so do you remember that or i don't
i'm sorry
no it's all right you get a bunch of
calls but i think today's question is
going to be a lot more straightforward
okay um i have a few but let's just see
how many i could
get in here so as you may know kanye has
announced his
uh bid for presidency this week uh
you know previously we saw his
relationship with trump
to positive um so really you know it
might just sound kind of weird the
question but i have this
this kind of like underlying feeling
that
it might be some type of trump
administration strategy to absorb that
crucial black
vote um you know would that just be
nonsense i mean you're not the first
person to bring this up to me the idea
would be
trump and kanye are friends joe biden
right now has 92 percent from black
voters
what better way to hurt biden than by
having
a black uh um a prominent black
entrepreneur and musical artists run
and take a little bit of the black vote
from biden that so so
the motive would certainly be there i
think what it misses
is that i don't believe black folks are
going to vote for kanye
who were otherwise going to vote for
biden there may be kanye fans who
weren't even planning to vote remember
half the country doesn't vote who i
guess might vote for kanye even though
he's still as far as i know to this day
he's not formally running anywhere he
just said he's running
but i think that it's fundamentally uh
you know insulting and dismissive of the
black community to if that's your plan
to imagine that the black community is
just going to vote for any black guy who
who
runs is not borne out by the evidence
and i think it's it's a bad strategy if
that's the strategy
yeah i also heard that he's missed some
crucial deadlines so i don't even think
it would be possible
if it comes down to it would you
actually ever consider voting
kanye over trump i guess you could you
would probably vote anything
other than trump uh yeah i mean i i
don't know about that you know
it's not occurred to me that that's ever
a position i would be in
so i'm going to opt out of even
answering that but i am no fan of kanye
um he seems extremely unstable i mean
over
trump it's like it's hard to justify
voting for trump over anyone
that'd be a tough one i don't know what
i would do
let me just see if you can answer this
one gizlane maxwell she was just
arrested and indicted
and from what i heard yesterday she has
like a bargaining chips
which is supposedly a bunch of videos
pictures or whatever
that's incriminating a lot of public
figures and influencers
do you have any ideas some of the names
we might be seeing in the near future
i have absolutely no idea i'm not going
to put the cart before
before the horse on that and i am
waiting to see
if and what comes of it uh and i've also
not
uh read the allegations that you're
citing all right sebastian i've got a
lot of people holding so i'm going to
move on
it sounds like you had a litany of
questions but i'm going to move on to
make sure
some other folks get an opportunity